hey everybody welcome back to park text
it's time for candy land today and
according to the scenario description
this is a candy themed amusement park
that operates on an all-inclusive basis
guests pay for entry but all food and
rides are free
use the income from admissions to
further develop the park
and well as i already said in the final
parts of brimstone peak
this is very hard compared to doing
everything on
ride admission so this is not going to
be the easiest
scenario and i'm very curious to see how
this goes
the goals though aren't too difficult we
need to have 600 guests in the park
and that's it there are many optional
goals
including have four coasters with an
excitement rating of 60 or above
have an experiences rating of at least
85 percent complete all goals without
using track right blueprints
we're definitely gonna make that because
well i never really use blueprints
and another optional goal that is
complete all non-optional goals by the
end of march year 3
which might be the hardest but then
again i think
i'm gonna have to do this thing very
quickly let's just take a look at the
park and see how it goes but something
that i can already predict
is we're just gonna have to constantly
grow our clientele because the problem
with these pay for entry parks
is that you make a lot of money up front
when people enter your park
but then as soon as they're in your park
you're not gonna make any money on them
anymore we can't even make money off of
food
so we really have to make sure that we
constantly get an influx of new guests
and build stuff and
try to reach these goals quickly because
if we start falling still
i think it could be a big problem
anyway before i start building i do want
to show off some of the rides that are
already here
because i think there are some really
interesting ones the scenery of this
map is not too candy themed but you can
definitely see
candy flown around everywhere and candy
colors everywhere let's
quickly take a ride on the b m invert
that we start out with
so this is kind of a terrain coaster
quick turn around and into a valley here
with a loop next to a path
kind of makes you wish the path was
going through the loop but
that's a lot harder to accomplish i
guess uh tunnel
into this crazy valley with water where
this thing does things that most real
life b
m inverts probably won't do
kind of ridiculous but i think it also
looks
cool enough especially as it flies over
the path here
and then with one more turn around we
are back
into the brakes there we go and we have
another b
m coaster here as well which ah perfect
timing
thank you this is our hyper coaster
well sort of i guess i'm not sure where
the other train is
but let's just go down this one big
hyper coaster drop
and then some kind of like twister hyper
coaster turnaround elements
a little bit like raging bull at six
flanks for instance
but yeah it's interesting too because
it's a little bit smaller than a typical
hyper coaster but it does do
hyper coaster stuff but it's also just
very terrain conforming
kind of an unusual layout really but
again like the invert very dependent on
the terrain
and the coaster layouts that i'm going
to build here as well
i think i do want to carry the same kind
of themes into those layouts as well
i think there's a potential for this
park to be a
crazy terrain-conforming coaster
paradise
so that's what i'm gonna go for as for
the money
you can already see i'm earning loads of
wad
but the problem is all of these people
are not gonna spend
any more money so sandra has
how much how much more money does she
have all of this money on hand
and we're not gonna be able to get any
of that it's so sad
it's really really sad i'm just gonna
have to constantly build stuff
and get new people into the park so the
question is
what can we build i think there are
plenty of options
it's really time to build that inverting
wooden coaster
really need to get that one in bobsled
coaster i see some potential for that
especially if it's terrain conforming
somewhere around hills and the water
coaster
could be combined with the river i'll
have to see about that one
but for sure i think i'm gonna put
research
into the coasters especially because
each coaster could maybe get a hundred
to two hundred new guests into the park
based on how popular they
are uh so given that we have a 20 well
actually a
30 entrance fee that's already 3
000 minimum of income that we get
just by building a new coaster so i
think that's the way we are gonna have
to start to reason
i'm just gonna have to get the most
guests out of my money
and see if we can get to 600 and
actually make those optional goals as
well
so without further ado let's get started
all right so right off the bat i just
want to talk about a few real life
things very quickly because
it's been a few months since i last
posted a video and you're probably
thinking self how are you not going to
acknowledge this at the start of your
video when you release a new one
well i will now but keep in mind that
self that you just heard
was actually recorded a few months ago
when i started
this episode and the silver right now is
speaking as i did the last recordings
and managed to finish this time lapse
it's been that long
simply because i don't like recording
things when i'm not inspired or
or motivated to do it i really just want
to keep doing this for fun
and if it's not fun i'm just gonna take
a break from things
so that's what happened recently it's
nothing personal my life otherwise has
been going pretty great
so if you're worried about me personally
it's all fine honestly
i just haven't been on this grind
particularly
although i also have been working on
youtube stuff i just haven't been able
to finish anything
but you might see some random little
projects
come up in the future i also have a
bunch of city skylines video propped up
but
you know that's stuff to talk about
later also i have to very quickly
give a shout out to maddie jazz jaren
and cuboid from the city skylines
community who are
the most beautiful people in the world
they didn't force me to say this or
anything
but you know i wanted to honor their
request and just
get it out there now let's get back to
uh park attacks and
talk a little bit about this first
coaster i
sort of made this map to force people to
kind of experiment with terrain
conforming coasters
which not gonna lie it's one of my
favorite things in this world
not just in real life you know real life
terrain conforming courses like wildfire
those things are absolutely awesome
helix also comes to mind
those are just some of my favorite rides
out there it's just
one of the the coolest ways to make sure
that you interact with
the environment of the coaster but also
get really cool layouts that stay
fast during the entire duration any
coaster that's not built on flatland
automatically much better honestly so
that was kind of the intention with this
scenario so that's also what i'm gonna
do with
the few rides that i'm gonna need to
build here to get to 600 guests and i
figured a wooden coaster would be
a good way to start this one is kind of
inspired by border dash although i do
have to
say that with a grain of salt already
included because obviously it has a loop
and a corkscrew but it does kind of do
the similar thing when the lift hill
goes up a hill
then you have a curve around drop and
then the rest of the layout tends to
stand much more
low to the ground and just be quite fast
for the station
i was trying something completely
different even though this is a
candyland
theme i wanted to experiment a little
bit and go for some kind of modern
glossy station roof cover honestly for
no other reason then
it's just something i hadn't tried yet
and i wanted to see how it would work
i'm kind of using this to test my
liberties
and yeah just come up with random ideas
i think
you know in a later sci-fi scenario or
something like this
this style could be useful but the
problem is that it's very organic
it it's more difficult and
time-consuming to achieve than it looks
honestly because whereas it looks very
simple the
the pattern is very random so every
corner is different and all the colors
are
a little bit different you've got that
sort of grid style in it
it's by no means difficult to achieve
but it is a a bit more of a tryhard
station than it looks like at the end of
the day it just looks like a glossy
rectangle and it doesn't
i don't know i feel like too much work
went into it for
what turned out to be the final product
but it's still
a pretty fun experience and um something
also fun to
to let it come back with the canopies on
the queue here
which are by no means something that i
haven't done on earlier scenarios but
here it kind of just makes those
triangles come back
and actually i i only realized this now
i actually didn't think about this when
i was building it but if anybody
remembers the abstract theme from roller
coaster tycoon
it had those glassy station buildings
where you could
select two colors and you'd have colored
panes of glass
it looks super similar to that theme
i wonder if my subconscious brain was
doing something there
i don't know honestly but now that i
think about it
it does seem kind of similar oh and
another thing that i was considering is
it does fit very well with the roof of
the bumper cars
so i figured why not just place that one
next to this thing
good work as a sort of mini area or at
least
a theme that works for this general part
of the park
in general this i would say is one of
the most roller coaster tycoon-ish
scenarios there are a lot of
inspirations that i went for
for the scenarios in this game but this
one particularly
feels very rollercoaster tycoon with the
the small path going through the whole
map
some terrain conforming coasters some
kind of difficult terrain to work with
that you have to snake your own rides
into
it's uh it's almost a little bit pained
by the numbers and i think the only
distinction is the way that the game is
played where everything's all inclusive
and of course the the unique theme that
the map comes with
um but yeah the general setup kind of
does remind me of
roller coaster one scenarios um
for this coaster also the supports were
looking a little bit wonky and i thought
it would be really cool to have a
sort of b m support structure now of
course it's kind of difficult to do that
with the cornices
of the building themes but i decided to
try it anyway
and here we get into another section
where i start building the
sled coaster it's a type of coaster i
don't build that much
because it's always kind of difficult to
turn it into an interesting layout when
all you
have to work with are really just
helixes um
i guess it's helix's anyway
i figured also it's it's a good type of
ride to put in here
it seemed like the kind of space that
would be
you know not it bobsled coasters are
always
difficult to fit into the space i feel
like there are always
other coaster types that can fit better
but
if any space in the map could fit a
bobsled coaster at least in my mind when
i was looking at it here
it would be this space and i was really
thinking you know i could have the
station
at some height drop down do one half of
the layout
then go into the chain lift and do the
finishing half the layout
that way um you can actually get a
decently
interesting layout where you don't spend
too much time
in you know the middle of nowhere
without any block breaks because these
things are also kind of an efficiency
nightmare
if you have one really long stretch of
track you're just gonna have a few
people in a train
and it's just gonna be too much time
that a second train
can't dispatch after it not to mention
that
these things in real life tend to have
many block breaks
if you go to europa park you look at
their bobsled coaster of this type
it basically does a turn and a small dip
and then it already
hit some look brakes that kind of stuff
is
understandable given how this coaster
functions in real life
but i wanted to avoid those shenanigans
and i feel like a mid
course lift hill that's not really a
term but it
sounds pretty good honestly uh what's
the best way to get around that issue
and yeah it pretty much works with the
way that this valley is set up here
and it also perfectly uh works with how
the the path
runs across the top of the valley so i
don't have to spend too much effort
trying to go over it or dig tunnels or
any of that stuff
i felt like digging tunnels could have
been a nice solution to get this bobsled
to go to different places
but it's also a little bit unrealistic
and i wanted to avoid
having to create two huge tunnels or
anything like that
now it was at this point that i realized
that i was
severely lacking in the toilets and
stalls department
so i figured where else to put some
important
infrastructure then at the start of the
map
you do start this map with some toilets
and installs
a small setup of it on the top right of
the map
or at least from the perspective that i
am right now
but nothing near the entrance and also i
figured
there's enough space here to build a
small building that fits in with the
entrance building the kind of big ben
looking
thing um so yeah i just decided to
attach that over there
and then over here we have a big valley
leading into the river
where there was pretty much enough space
to build a small flat ride
so i decided to put this thing here not
too much to it otherwise but
you know when we need to get to 600
guests all the little bits help
and this was just a good way to add some
kind of
visual counterweight also to the station
of the bobsled coaster
and make this whole area a little bit
more interesting for all the people
visiting it
also i imagine this ride could actually
have a really good view
i don't know how much you can actually
focus on that
given how intense that thing is but you
know i think it works
more or less and then when it comes to
the uh the architecture
it's very standard architecture honestly
i'm not even going with anything
crazy it's just very typical traditional
coaster station
except it's made out of chocolate pieces
and it has a bunch of
candy flown around that's just
how it works here anyway next coaster
and this
is well personally i think my highlights
of this park a flawless coaster that is
almost looking a little bit hair
razor-ish in
hong kong's ocean park with this color
scheme and being built up that hill like
that
especially with that kind of curved drop
anyway that wasn't
particularly the inspiration i don't
think there was any particular coaster
that
inspired me to build this way i just saw
that hill
saw an opportunity for a good lift hill
and saw an opportunity for
a good second section as well where you
dip into that valley you get a lot lower
and use most of your momentum until you
get back into the station
because with terrain conforming coasters
that's always the challenge where
you put your higher sections where do
you go when you go to the lower sections
takes a little bit of
planning beforehand or even a little bit
of try on error
you might also notice me struggling a
lot in this section
trying to figure out how i can snake
back and forth and
not run into my earlier pieces of track
but eventually we get there
so yeah we just start snaking around
these crazy inversions here
and with enough try on error and
trying to see how i can work this thing
up and down
um usually you come at some sort of
solution
i think what's really useful in these
cases as well if you're ever struggling
with something like this where the
elements are very close together
is just messing with different heights
and different
bankings sometimes you can make a curve
if you just get the banking right
um but yeah in the end i decided to
not go through the loop or anything like
that because there just wasn't enough
space
to make it over the curve that i had
made over the water next to the station
there
and i figured it wasn't really necessary
to make the approach into the station
straight if i have enough space for
a break section and block brakes then
it doesn't really matter what direction
it's going plus this way i don't get
anything that's too convoluted
and we have a nice gentle way back into
the station
because this station building is
something where i really wanted to
experiment
so far i've been playing it very safe on
the scenery
side of things just kind of copying the
scenery style that's already in the map
but with this coaster i wanted to see if
i could take it a little bit further
my idea was to build some kind of castle
except a little bit gingerbreadish and
not completely
mind you i didn't want to make the the
whole thing candy themed
you might also notice i'm not making
everything candy themed you know i'm
trying to
make it a bit more realistic so i'm
putting down trees and
putting down decorations between them
that resemble candy but not making
everything
an unrealistic candy land i think this
could still exist
in real life reasonably in some kind of
candy themed world if that were ever to
exist in a theme park
so yeah for this castle most of the
bases as you can see is just
regular walls it's really just in the
colors
and the decoration that you can see that
this turns into some kind of
cake slash candy thing
but mostly it's just a disney castle
which
i haven't done enough of these things in
parchitect i think
when it comes to parchitect my favorite
things are always trying to overcome the
limitations of the game because
obviously you don't have that many
pieces so when you want to do really
intricate things like a disney castle
that has a lot of vertical elements
it's always really challenging and i
think it's really fun because you don't
have
many of these especially vertical
decorative gothic
elements that a real life disney castle
has so you really try
to bring it out with the shape and the
colors that you're working with
and in this case that was mostly by
adding extra height
using the walls and using those round
basic shapes to build a main tower
using the spire in the middle which is a
super useful piece
to also add some verticality and putting
it on a big
more horizontal pedestal of that bottom
roof and i think it
more or less works out you know it's not
it's obviously not a perfect
disney car so it's not a copy or
anything but it does have the same kind
of vibe
very vertical much more decorative than
real life castles
and basically inspired by the
overdone fanciness of neuschwanstein
um so yeah this stuff is really fun i've
come to realize i i might need to do
this
a little bit more i think in general my
park tech builds have always been
a lot more horizontal if that makes any
sense
given the fact that you don't have that
many decorative vertical elements in the
game
and while i do always add lots of
pillars and spires the corners and roofs
and stuff like that
i feel like vertical building is
something i could do a little bit more
with
and this was a fun experience in that
sense
especially with some of the off-grid
elements that you can place
like dormers and some of the windows
that you can place off-grid but
also definitely the candy decorations
i think there's a lot of creative stuff
that you can do
and i think that's also the beauty of
park attack's minimalist
style and art style the fact that you
don't even really need to have pieces of
a certain theme
to build with that certain theme as long
as you know what
makes that theme work the certain color
schemes
the shapes of buildings the general vibe
you can basically
do anything with the basic shapes and
roof shapes
of this game so that that's also where
my challenge was for this building
to use as little of the candy theme as
possible
only using it here and there for
decorations and small nooks and crannies
but still make this building feel like
it was at home
in the candy world and i think
it more or less works out i think if i
add up all of the candy elements the
most important part would be the walls
although they're also not that big of an
influence but they are the cookie walls
then of course on the top of the tower
we have big cookies
kind of functioning as the the clock
faces
which you would normally perhaps have
there and then we have little
um cream puffs on top of the uh
the spires as extra decorations so you
can also see you have the smaller puffs
on the smaller spires that kind of stuff
was just really fun to add
and then also the the cream filling or
whatever it is
the the creamy stuff on the the ridges
of the roofs
and i think that's mostly it yeah some
some candy pillars and stuff like that
but the majority
of the building ends up being non-candy
pieces
oh and speaking of using pieces in a
different way than they're
meant for for this area i was thinking
for a while it looks a little bit empty
what if i could do something more with
it and
we have these cotton candy trees in the
game
and i thought what if i just lower these
things into the ground and just spread
them around this coaster as some kind of
cotton candy theme for this area make it
look a little bit more interesting and
candy-like
without making it completely undoable
i do realize that looking at time lapse
you know keep in mind this is
sped up 12 times you can see the trees
move around a lot which does look a
little bit strange
but then when you're in real time you
don't really notice it as much
because it's a lot slower so i don't
think it's that much of an obstacle but
yeah definitely looks a little bit
strange here and then i also replaced
the the candy and pimped the the station
in general a little bit
make it a bit more interesting than the
flat box it was before
although it's still a box it just has a
bit more
going on now and some cotton candy and
cream about
just to fit in with the general
surroundings of this coaster
oh and at this point i realized that i
could probably already reach the guest
core of 600 guests if i just ran some
advertisements
so i quickly turned on some
advertisements and
you guys will see in a minute that um it
might be a little bit easier to reach
the goals at this point
than i expected while i was building but
anyway in the meantime
i decided to build some balconies
balconies what am i saying
i decided to build some catwalks on the
bobsled coaster because
even though these things don't
necessarily have them in real life i
thought it would look pretty cool
it just looked kind of empty without
these things so
some simple roofs and um yeah there you
go
i reached the goal we'll get to that in
a second but yeah some simple roof
pieces
and cornices in the color of the
chocolates that i have around the park
is basically all i added to this thing
and
that's it that's basically this map
completed
so let's take a look and see how it
turned out
all right so that was candyland i'm a
little bit mad at myself that i missed
the final
celebration of reaching the goals
normally i always try to time it in such
a way that i can
get into this last section of the video
and in real time see the confetti flying
on the screen and it's it's all great
this time i sort of missed that i was
already hitting the goals while i was
building some fences on the bobsled
coaster here
and also i kind of thought i would have
to hold the goal of 600 guests for three
months but that turned out not to be the
case
so i just instantly finished the
scenario when i totally thought i
wouldn't
um so i'm sorry i missed out on that
moment on the bright side though
i did reach the optional goals as well
and i managed to finish the scenario by
actually august it's already september
but i managed to finish
it in august of year two in instead of
you know the deadline of
march year three so that's pretty good
and all together
it's not really my favorite outcome even
though this was one of my favorite
scenarios to build just for how coaster
and terrain focused it is
i'm just not really the best at the the
candy theme
as i've kind of expressed earlier on in
this video there are some people who
really go boss to the wall with the
thing with this theme but
it's not really my forte i suppose plus
it is a scenario where everything's
inclusive and
you have to make money off of the
entrance fee which you can kind of
cheese by closing and opening the park
regularly but it's not something which
i'm the best at my personal kind of
preferred gameplay
is making money via rights instead of
the park entrance but you know
you need some kind of variety in the
game as well so i get why it's uh
it's different in this one but anyway
let's do a quick rundown of the rides
uh that i've built in this scenario and
see how they all go let's start with the
floorless this is probably my favorite
ride and
really also the signature at least of
the rides that i've built i feel like
the two coasters that you start off with
in this scenario are already
signature rides and it's hard to um
imminent bankruptcy whatever i've
already made the goals of this scenario
but yeah it's hard to make anything to
you know become more iconic than those
things already are
but i do love how this one flies by over
the station uh it has that lift hill
that really
goes up a hill and then i had to like
somehow wiggle it into this lower space
here
because the thing with terrain coasters
is always you have to find that
compromise with the terrain where you
can find a hill
that's suitable for the lift hill to go
up but then also a valley that's good
for
the lower section of the ride to go down
into and then into the break run of the
station i think
some of the coasters at alton towers who
do this really well like nemesis
i think nemesis is always an example for
me not just because it's terrain
conforming but
how it manages to find a space for the
early half of the ride and the latter
half of the ride and i think
you know this is also trying to do that
where you have like the high section
and the low section and and maybe you
kind of even
recognize that in some other courses
although this woody here has a more
boulder dash
approach to terrain conforming coasters
i suppose where it just uses the terrain
to get up really high
for this section over here does a bit of
a wildfire curve
and then drops down into the cliff which
works so well i think even with the head
choppers down there and then straight
into the vertical loop
that has to be a really cool moment in
real life um
and then at that point it just kind of
turns into a border dash ish
gci esque ride it's not really the most
fast or thrilling woody um but you know
there wasn't
too much space or terrain to work with
and given what we have and the kind of
limitations that you have with this map
i think it works out all right enough
you know i said that this wasn't
you know my best map when it comes to my
play style i think that mostly refers to
scenery
it's not the kind of theme where i can
go crazy i just kind of played it safe
and
stuck with the scenery that was already
there mostly
maybe pimp it a little bit here and
there when it comes to the trees or
an area like this but mostly kind of
playing it safe but
i do think this is a really cool map for
roller coasters you know coming out with
layouts and
seeing what you can do with the terrain
making all of these terrain conforming
coasters
and finally let's take a quick look at
the bobsled
let's see if i can actually get a pov of
the one in the station here
uh yeah there we go these are always
kind of difficult to turn
into a really interesting coaster
because i guess there's not
that much variety that you have when it
comes to playing with the layout it's
just
helixes until you arrive back at the
station
so yeah this layout's kind of playing it
safe although i do like how it's
divided into two halves with the lift
hill in the middle
it makes it a more interesting
experience i suppose but it also does
help the capacity of this ride a lot
because it means you can run
you know perfect block sections get the
train into the station
unload and load everybody and go into
the next one i see i have to ban
somebody
hmm all right there we go my park is
slowly falling apart and going bankrupt
in the background
but you know that doesn't matter i uh i
threw
everything into making the scenario in
the end here so i had lots of
advertisements running
you know built a lot of stuff with the
last money that i had
and then just with the right timing
managed to reach the goal so
somebody's gonna have to take this park
over after me and i'm glad i don't have
to worry about it
i did what i had to you know and now
it's somebody else's responsibility i
guess
but yeah that's uh that's candyland for
today
so with all that said let's take a look
and see what the next map is because i
honestly don't remember
i have a little bit of an inkling but
we'll see what we'll get
so first of all of course we're gonna
get some kind of trophy for this
ah it's the entrance building i love how
you can
very clearly tell it's big ben inspired
on the left here it's basically just
biscuit big ben uh or you know the
elizabeth tower
for the people who are aware that the
tower isn't actually called big man
anyway i'm going so off topic the next
one is
oh it's actually not what i thought it
would be it's timber creek
oh that's gonna be interesting that's
gonna be really interesting
if you're watching this you probably
already have an idea of what most
scenarios are like but if you don't
this one's going to be very different
from all the scenarios so far you can
probably tell from there
the weird list of goals that we have to
reach for this one
anyway that's an assignment for next
time i'd like to thank you guys for
watching
and i hope to see you in the next video
bye